-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
What a show.
You guys, today is officially
the first day of fall.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Of course, some people are
sad that summer's over,
but good news -- thanks
to climate change, it's not.
That's right -- we're entering
that magical time of year where
we put on old jackets hoping to
find cash in the pockets.
You know, "Some gum."
Let's get to some news.
After speaking here
in New York City
at the UN General Assembly,
President Biden
is back in Washington, and
today, he hosted world leaders
for a virtual summit
about COVID.
Yep, world leaders
traveled 4,000 miles to New York
just so they could Zoom from
their rooms at the Best Western.
Well, the summit lasted
more than four hours.
Four hours!
By the end,
everyone was fatigued.
Everyone had body aches,
sore throats.
They we like, "Wait.
Do we have COVID?"
But the big takeaway from
the summit is that Biden
wants world leaders
to fully vaccinate 70%
of their population.
Then world leaders were like,
"Okay, you first.
Deal. You..."
But this is good -- at the
summit, Biden announced that
the U.S. is buying an additional
500 million doses of
the Pfizer vaccine to share with
countries around the world.
Each country
will receive a basket with
an injectable arrangement,
which is interesting.
That's right --
The White House says
they're gonna to start
sending the doses in January.
Seriously, January?
Countries are like, "If I sign
up for Government Prime,
can I get that tomorrow?
January? Wow."
This is amazing.
Last night,
the winning ticket for
the $432 million
Mega Millions jackpot
was sold a block away from our
studio, at Pronto Pizza.
-Ooh!
-Dang!
-When asked what they'll do with
$432 million, the winner said,
"Hey, it's New York City.
I'm gonna move from my studio
to a one-bedroom.
Come on.
Yeah."
Pronto Pizza.
And, finally, I saw
that Aston Martin is selling
a James Bond car for kids,
and it costs $123,000.
The kid who gets one
is going to be like,
"I'm a brat.
Spoiled brat."
Welcome to the show.
Just a reminder
to tune in tomorrow night.
We're partnering with Samsung
to do a very special show
from all five boroughs of
New York City --
Manhattan, Queens, Brooklyn,
Staten Island, and the Bronx.
There's lots of surprises.
The Killers are going to perform
at the Top of The Rock.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And you'll get to
see me throw out
the first pitch at
a Yankees game.
-Ooh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's tomorrow night.
-Tomorrow night.
-You don't want to miss it,
but if you happen to miss it...
-Yeah, it's okay.
-Dude, I got to be
honest, man --
throwing out the first pitch,
this is a lot of pressure.
I never wanted to do this thing.
And now I apologize to Questlove
because I've made fun of
his first pitch.
-You did a lot.
-No, not really.
I just played it.
-You just played it a little.
-I just played it,
and the audience laughed.
I laughed with it.
-Not at him.
I laughed with the video.
-What you did --
you took Kamal's advice.
Kamal said, "Just throw it
into the stands."
-No, I didn't throw it
into the stands.
-Yeah, obviously.
-Well, the catcher caught it.
-Yeah.
-So, yeah.
-Was he at home base
when he caught it
or did he --
-No, he was definitely
at home base.
He might have even
jumped up a little.
-Yeah, he jumped.
-So, the most --
-Here's the thing.
-I think the
most important thing was
doing better than Quest, right?
-Yeah, that was the whole goal.
-Right.
-Yeah, so, I did that.
But it was definitely --
[ Laughter ]
-Did you?
-It's definitely
a lot of pressure.
Did you throw from the mound
or you throw from
in front of the mound?
-I threw it from the mound.
-I was on the mound.
-Wow.
-I went all the way up
to the mound.
-Yeah.
-I didn't have
any rehearsal at all.
-No rehearsal with the sports.
No.
-No, I mean...
-That's great.
-What I --
[ Cheers and applause ]
You start shaking.
I was like -- Mariano Rivera,
who's amazing,
the greatest pitcher
of all time --
greatest relief pitcher --
was there,
and he kind of helped me out.
You'll see it tomorrow.
And he was a great guy.
I'll talk more about
Mariano on Friday.
But I kept thinking about Quest,
because it's a lot --
I started just kind of shaking,
because I had never been
that nervous in a while.
And there wasn't that many
people in the stands still yet,
and so I was kind of happy
that not that many --
But then I forgot
that it's broadcast
to millions of people.
And, so, I get up there
and I go,
"Alright, so, don't --
don't hit the dirt."
That's the one thing.
And when you throw out
a first pitch,
people that know
you're throwing it out
start sending you
clips of bad pitches,
and they go, "Don't do this.
Don't do this one
or don't do that one."
I go -- And I got 25 clips of
Questlove throwing the ball,
and I go --
-From different angles?
-I'm joking. I'm joking.
Different? No. I'm joking.
-You were laughing
with him again.
-Yeah. So, I get -- So, anyways,
I do it and I go just --
And then I go up to the mound,
and it seems further away
than possible.
Like, when was the last time you
threw anything 60 feet?
-Never.
-Well...
-I can't even walk 60 feet
without running out of --
-Yeah, I had to throw
a ball 60 feet.
And I'm not an athlete.
These guys are
professional athletes.
A lot of credit to
the baseball players.
But I threw it and I was just
kind of nervous even doing that.
I even, like -- When I went
back, I kind of rocked into it.
-Mm-hmm. That's good.
-Like, I've never --
I've never seen anyone do --
-Wait. Do it again. Do it again.
-I did like a --
-Like The Temptations?
-♪ Sugar pie, honeybunch ♪
♪ You know that I love you ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ I can't help my-- ♪
I was doing --
You know, so, I rocked --
I rocked into it
too much to kick it out.
-Right.
-So, what I was doing --
I was choreographing,
way overthinking.
I'm like...
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I was doing --
It was terrible.
And then I released it.
Oh, I kicked --
-What?!
-I release, follow through.
-Right.
-And it was almost like
a combination of, like,
Bret Saberhagen...
-Right.
-...and Dr. Fauci.
It was one of those two.
-Yeah.
-It didn't quite work,
but it did work.
And then I just kind of said,
"Yeah, alright, good."
And I just said, "Okay."
And I just --
I didn't even text Quest,
because I just go,
"Hopefully he didn't see it."
-I was watching you.
-I know you did.
But you'll see it tomorrow.
And, again, thank you
to the Yankees.
It's an honor to do it.
-Yeah.
-So much pressure.
I was like, "Oh, my gosh!"
Quest, I apologize.
It's a tough thing to do.
[ Applause ]
You'll see it tomorrow night
on our show
and you'll see exactly
what went down.
But let's talk about
our show tonight.
They star in the new Hulu series
"Only Murders in the Building."
Steve Martin
and Martin Short are here.
-Oh, come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
In studio.
-"Only Murders in the Building."
-So great.
-Plus, you can see her in
the new limited series "Maid,"
premiering October 1st
on Netflix.
Margaret Qualley is here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
My partner, my pal.
And we have an in-studio
performance from Cynthia Erivo!
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Look at that.
Gorgeous, sounds great.
Get ready. What a show tonight.
Also, this is
a special night to be here,
because it is Climate Night.
Tonight, we're joining up with
all the other late-night shows
to raise awareness
about climate change.
And tonight, we have our special
guest Dr. Jane Goodall on.
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on.
-My favorite.
I love her.
-Come on.
-She is unbelievable.
She's going to be on the show
to talk about
a new campaign, Trees for Jane.
If you want to learn more about
how to help,
go to the climategroup.org,
and you can follow along tonight
by using the hashtag
"ClimateNight."
It's a cool thing, and we're
very happy to be a part of it.
Thanks.
[ Cheers and applause ]